when the world is a belt a mess
there's plenty of myths with the economy
right now but there's always solace in
music they're setting up for the night
at the Phoenix Arts Club in London Soho
but even here the cost of living crisis
is hard to escape the Cottages rising
and Rising we work with several
suppliers across food and beverage
across electricity gas all of the
standard utilities that everyone pays
really but add a zero or a couple of
zeros to that and that's what it looks
like for a small business it's quite
scary actually and for many households
especially those with mortgages
especially those about to refix their
loans it is scary and the bank which has
raised rates again to 4.5 percent says
there's more pain to come we know that
by the end of this year there will be a
lot more mortgages that will reset
because fixed rate so it's coming for
millions of households and so we yeah
but we fact and we factored that in so
how much of the pain have we had so far
on that and how much has yet to come in
terms of resetting and adjustments it's
probably normal about a third but just
in terms of what her families can expect
so there is still two-thirds of the kind
of interest rate related pain yet to
come it's quite a large portion of
mortgages yet to reset that pain that
monetary squeeze is what mortgage
brokers around the country are now
having to help deliver it's not
it can be more stressful the pressure on
people to make quick decisions is hard
any more rate increases are going to be
quite
um hard to manage for a lot of
households in the UK and not only the
mortgages go in or obviously the bills
have gone up with that as well still
there was some good news from the bank
now surprising as it might sound given
the economic climate the bank has just
delivered the biggest upgrade to their
economic growth forecast that they have
ever seen the issue is they are starting
from such a miserable place that where
they are now is basically just about
flatlining the deeper issue though for
this institution is they've got so many
of their forecasts wrong in the past
that people are asking whether they can
actually rely on them at all
the governor denies there's a
credibility problem you keep getting it
wrong I mean is is the simple truth here
that basically the bank isn't very good
at forecasting
I don't agree with that you know we're
experiencing huge external shocks those
external shocks are frankly not
something you can forecast as such I
think things like the war sort of War
you can't forecast the pump was missing
its forecast before the war it was
missing its forecasts before the big the
big rise because there was because there
was an impact from 2021 there was an
apart from covid on on what we tend to
call Supply chains regardless of whether
it was foreseeable the upshot is we're
all poorer says the bank a tough message
for those working hard to make a living
I feel poorer and it's not like we have
crazy expensive Lifestyles anyway living
costs going up electricity gas
um like you say commute here is not
cheap at all I wish it was at some point
the economy will recover at some point
the news will get better but the latest
message from the bank is not quite yet
at Conway Sky News